everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm so they're gonna be looking
at round two from the 2015 norway chess
tournament one of the biggest
tournaments of the year pretty much all
the big names are gonna be playing here
ran one was pretty exciting when we saw
Magnus Carlsen actually lose on time in
a winning position didn't quite
understand that the time constraints had
changed from last year and so he lost a
winning position while he had the white
pieces so he's gonna be looking for a
comeback here in Game two and I thought
this would be a super exciting match
because his opponent is the number-two
ranked player in the world
Fabiana Caruana young superstar and so
we have the number one ranked player in
the world of Fabiano playing the white
pieces and Magnus Carlsen playing the
back black pieces Magnus Carlsen
being the world champion at the moment
so Fabi Ellen starts out with pawn to e4
pawn e5 Knight f3 Knight to c6 Bishop
here to b5 the Rui Lopez and then Knight
to f6 from a magnetic Asin this is the
Berlin defense a very strong defense a
lot of times you may hear it referred to
as the Berlin Wall because it's so tough
for whites to really break through and
find a victory a lot of times this will
end up in a draw and Fabiano
I'm sure is looking for more than that
he tied in the first round knows that
he's gonna have to to get some victories
in this tournament win Magnus Carlsen on
the other side wants to kind of make
sure that he can come back wants to play
an opening that he's familiar with he
played the Berlin defence against Vichy
and on in the World Championship last
year three times so he's very very
familiar with it plays it all the time
has a few different variations that
we're gonna see today which are kind of
exciting some novelties in the opening
but all in all looking to be a very very
fun match Fabiano castles on the Kings
side and then Magnus Carlsen stakes here
on e4 this kind of open variation he
plays this more than anything else I
also like to personally play bishop here
to c5 kind of that classical line in the
Berlin defense but Magnus Carlsen
he has kind of prepared specifically for
this so he plays what he's comfortable
Knight to Eve
and then we see pawn to d4 these kind of
the main lines here the Knights gonna
come back here to these six a Bishop to
c6 pawn taking here on c6 pawn taking
here and that over here to f5 Queen take
King take and then pawn to h3 this is
where we start to see some novelties in
the game we see magnus carlsen play pawn
to h6 a lot of times in the World
Championships we would either see the
King come here to e8 we might even see
Bishop here to d7 both of the moves that
we saw decides to go ahead and play pawn
to h6 playing pawn to h5 even later in
the opening is something that black can
do in the Berlin defense so starting off
with pawn to h6 something we don't
always see and then rook over here to a
d1 and then a king here to e now if we
look at the board
a white definitely has a little bit of
advantage as far as he's a little bit
more established as king right now is a
little bit safer it's not as big of a
deal if your opponent's queen is off the
board
your Kings fairly safe black does have
the double bishop pair so why it's gonna
have to make sure that he continues to
press forward he does have kind of the
spatial advantage here because if Magnus
Carlsen can keep this open board and get
his double Bishop pears involved into
the game it's gonna put a lot of
pressure on Fabi out on Caruana so
Fabiano needs to make sure that he
controls the middle of the board with
his rooks he needs to make sure that his
Knights are both very active and he
continued to put pressure with these
pawns on board Knight here to c3 Knight
coming back here to e7 this is also an
interesting move Magnus Carlsen playing
somewhat of a novel line here that's you
don't see all that often usually from
here you'll see Bishop here to 6 you may
see Bishop here to e7 some common moves
usually the night here on f5 is going to
stay here even in the World Championship
you saw pawn coming here to b6 and
Bishop coming here to a6 trying to
control this long LightSquared diagonal
right here but decides to go ahead and
play something different plays knight
here to e7 and then after pawn to b3 we
see Bishop here to f5 and this is
something that Magnus Carlsen didn't
think that Fabiana
be prepared for after the matches they
kind of talked to both players Fabiana
said yeah actually had looked at this
specific line and was prepared for it
and had a game plan for it so it'd be
interesting to see how both Fabiano's
preparation versus Magnus Carlsen who
knows the berlin defense maybe better
than anyone is going to play out to end
this match with the bishop here on f5
attacking this pawn
Fabiana decides to go and bring his
knight here to d4 centralizing his
knight but also protecting this pawn
then we see the bishop come back here to
h7 is being attacked but magnus carlsen
wants to maintain the pressure here on
c2 let me see bishop here to be - just
controlling this long dark diagonal
right here
rook over here to d8 putting pressure on
this night right here black's goal is
really to remove this defender right
here if this night falls away all of a
sudden this pawns going to fall - this
bishop right here so we see the knight
come back here that's a great snooze
that's now protecting this Knights here
and also if this night falls can take
its place with this Knights and then
still protecting right here and this
dark square Bishop Baron b2 is also
protecting it as well so if I be on
doing a good job of kind of maneuvering
his pieces around and still holding
control of the important squares that he
needs to Knight here to e5 just more of
a central square does open up the board
for this dark square bishop as well to
get involved which magnus carlsen
definitely needs to do piling up here to
see for threatening to move this knight
then that comes back here to be for a
knight up here to f4 as well trying to
get ready to attack on the King side and
then rook over here to GA now this is
another novelty that magnus carlsen said
he prepared it was interesting Fabiana
said he didn't like this move instead
perfor prefered maybe something more
active like bishop here to e7 just
getting it outside protecting these dark
squares a little bit more instead we did
see magnus carlsen play rook here to g8
so this was in his preparation now we
see pawn to g4 so fabio decides hey I'm
just gonna start to attack with my pawns
right here and so he continues to
Ford and then Knight to a6 and this is
the first move where in the preparation
I I just don't understand why magnus
carlsen decided for this i think he has
better options besides Knight here to a6
there's no real threat it's gonna be
very difficult for him he's gonna waste
a lot of moves to kind of get this
active over on the kingside as soon as I
see pawn here to g4 I'm gonna be looking
to keep safe on the kingside I'm gonna
play Bishop here to e7 I want things as
safe as possible I don't want to be
worrying about my knight over here but
magnus carlsen decides to play Knight
over here to a6 now Knight here to f5
kind of shutting the door on this Bishop
here on h7 which is not what Magnus
Carlsen is looking to do now Knight over
here to c5 as we kind of alluded to
Magnus Carlsen kind of using his moves
to get his Knights over on the Kings
side
rook up here to d8 exchange right here
and then to d1 so white has a much more
active rook this d1 is gonna be able to
fly around this entire board this rook
over here on GA for Magnus Carlsen isn't
doing much at all except protecting this
pawn right here and it's not gonna be
active for a while because there's not a
lot of room for this dark square bishop
here to get out anywhere it's kind of
blocked out not only by its knight but
also this pawn right here on e5 is kind
of a pain so right now Fabiano is doing
a great job of controlling the game he's
being aggressive like he needs to and
Magnus Carlsen
he's just playing defense these bishops
aren't moving his rooks not moving as
Knights kind of dancing around the board
can now get it over on the Kings side
and kind of help out in the defense but
really doesn't have a lot going for him
right now so he just needs to hold on
and make sure he does not get out of
this game down zero tie zero wins and
two losses that would definitely be very
bad especially since he's Norwegian and
he's playing at the Norway Chest 2015
tournament we're now seeing Magnus
Carlsen play a king to c8 and then
Bishop here to a3 attacking the knight
and that's going to come back here to
East six finally made its way over to
the Kings side then we see the knight
take here on e6 now very important that
Magnus Carlsen takes
correctly if you were to take let's say
with his pawn here on e6 then all of a
sudden Fabiano has a really creative
move a bishop here to e7 we can clearly
see that the bishop takes the Knights
going to take that's going to force the
knight that's going to be extremely bad
but if he doesn't take that let's say he
plays something else because he needs to
get his King out so let's say you plays
the pawn here to b5 then just the risk
can come up here and then the bishops
going to take here on f8
the pawn is going to take the Knights
but then this pawns are just gonna start
pushing up forward it's gonna be very
very difficult for black to do too much
on board so instead Magnus Carlsen
decides to go and take with his Bishop
which is what he needs to do but now the
Knights gonna come over here to g7 take
still has this defender right here
Bishop has to come back to help but then
pawn to e6 is really really difficult
for Magnus Carlsen to deal with he has
to play precisely and then he's still
going to be in a lot of danger so he
takes with his bishop right here he does
not want to take in correctly here as
well if you were to take with his pawn
then all of a sudden the Knights going
to take can either take either the
bishop here or we could see the rook
come up here to d8 the bishop can't just
come here to kind of stop that because
then the knight could take it's just all
sorts of bad news right here but decides
to go and take correctly it takes when
this bishop here on f5 and then the
knight takes and now the pawn takes here
on e6 and then the sights can come back
here to g3
poppy on the sides he doesn't have to be
too aggressive right now with his knight
he can kind of regroup a little bit he
doesn't have the pieces to kind of stay
over there and be somewhat aggressive
but he has the better pawn structure
both sides are equal in material but
really Fabiano has a much easier in game
anytime your opponent has one minor
piece and that is a bishop all you have
to do is put your pawns on the other
color and pretty much that bishop
becomes useless
so Fabiana he can just put all his pawns
on light squares and this dark square
Bishop is not going to be able to do too
much
it can stop a promotion if it doesn't
want to let's say this pawn here on f2
it's eventually going to promote to f8
but besides that the bishops not gonna
be doing too much so Fabiano definitely
has a leg up right now he also has a
better pawn structure he has three pawns
on the kingside he can kind of overload
the King decide it's going to be very
difficult for Magnus Carlsen they kind
of overload the Queen's eyes and Saul's
material right now is over on the Queen
R on the King side so we see Bishop here
to e7 King up here to g2 definitely want
to make sure you get your kings involved
into the game especially middle to the
late-game when there's not as much big
material boards the Queen's and the
rooks too to really put pressure on the
King there's no real mate threats that
the King has to worry about so it's an
extra piece in the attack so make sure
you get it involved into the center of
the board
rook over here to f8 rook appear to d3
both of these players getting into the
endgame
Fabiana just kind of maneuvering his
pieces around and wants to make sure he
doesn't really put any of his pieces on
the dark squares if he doesn't have to
but you know pawn appear to f4 doesn't
have to worry too much this night here
on h5 is protecting that [ __ ] appear to
a3 isn't doing too much at all King up
here to f3 just more and more pressure
see Magnus Carlsen is not making any
headway with his paws and Fabiana
Caruana is continuously putting more and
more pressure by pushing up his pawns
even more so King here to d7 does
finally get his King involved into the
game but after a few more moves we do
see just too much pressure on board rook
over here to e e8 spawn up here to f5
eventually one of these is going to
break through and then King here to f4
doesn't even want to take with his King
yet although he could doesn't have to
worry too much but maybe the sides
doesn't want to just have to worry about
rook here to f8 and then forcing the
King to move so instead I decided to
play a little bit safer bring his King
over here to f4 and then take with his
knights after the bishop comes then
Fabiana plays rook over here to g2 he's
threatening both Knight taking here on
h6 he's threatening with a pawn pushing
forward with both the knight and the
rook here as protectors this King just
can't get involved
enough and to magnus carlsen is forced
to resign and loses the first two
matches he's got to be pretty
disappointing after the first match he
felt like he had won he was just sitting
there trying to calculate the winning
combination and ran out of time kind of
a shock to all of us so the norwegian is
currently getting destroyed in the
norway chest term it's a lot of play
left we got many many more days left of
tournament play so magnus carlsen said
he's going to come back fired up and he
thinks he can still win this thing
of Fabiana caruana playing fantastic
chess I think him or Nakamura is going
to take this down both of them just
extremely talented players but all in
all really great match excited for this
tournament so many great games are gonna
be coming out of this tournament so many
top players so if you have a favorite
player let me know I'll try to make sure
I do commentary on their match but
hopefully you guys enjoyed this number
one versus number two in the world is
always exciting in any sport especially
chess and yes chess in my opinion is a
sport so take that for what it is and
I'll see you guys in the next game
thanks for watching everybody